[Musique]
le grand matin Sud Radio 7 heures 9
heures Patrick Roger et l'invité
ce matin
la finale des républicains sur tire
quelle stratégie face au gouvernement
les républicains et Nicolas Sarkozy qui
a rendez-vous devant la justice
aujourd'hui et puis les questions
d'actualité c'est ce que nous allons
voir ensemble commençons par l'élection
à la présidence des LR donc le poste que
vous occupez en fait aujourd'hui
présidente Bruno Retailleau 34 et demi
Éric Ciotti 42,7 se sont qualifiés donc
pour le second tour Aurélien Pradier 22
9 très précisément été éliminé c'était
un score attendu ou pas
on avait on était un peu à l'aveugle
puisqu'il n'y avait aucun sondage
voilà le résultat
personne ne s'est écroulé je trouve que
la campagne a été absolument remarquable
d'engagement ils se sont énormément
déplacés ils ont rencontré des milliers
de d'adhérents ça a été une campagne
finalement très respectueuse des
adhérents des républicains et moi de lui
retire mon chapeau parce que la qualité
de leur campagne et bien ce de mérite
d'être salué et d'être et d'être
remarqué parce que vraiment ils ont
mouillé la chemise bon d'accord donc une
campagne qui s'est bien déroulée
en revanche sur le la sincérité du
scrutin là il y a un doute parce que
vous avez vu les chats de la direction
du JDD ont pu voter qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette histoire alors il y a des il y
a des failles
écoutez aucun parti n'a mis en place des
procédures aussi rigoureuses que celles
que nous avons mises en place c'est une
escroquerie cette histoire lorsque vous
adhérez au républicains vous devez
déclarer sur l'honneur que vous êtes une
personne physique et que le règlement ne
se fait pas par une personne morale
voilà donc dès lors qu'il y avait des
adhésions multiples il y avait des
vérifications qui étaient opérées à
partir de 4 donc le JDD a voulu
démontrer que et bien on pouvait
commettre une escroquerie ce qu'ils ont
fait et jetez ainsi le discrédit non
seulement sur une élection mais sur un
parti je trouve ça profondément choquant
et nous réfléchissons ensuite à donner
parce que si le JDD avait fait la même
opération pour tous les partis
politiques en démontrant que oui il y a
des failles comme il peut y avoir des
failles dans un magasin contre le vol on
peut toujours voler dans un magasin et
dire oui à des failles c'est vrai mais
dans toute organisation humaine il peut
y avoir des failles seulement le JDD n'a
fait cela que pour les républicains un
jour il y avait eu l'affaire du chien
Douglas déjà à la primaire quoi
le chien n'avait pas pu voter il faut
savoir bon là le JDD est parti avec un
une volonté de démontrer que c'est
c'était possible en usant la stratagème
d'une escroquerie et je veux dire à quel
point je suis
interrogative sur la
déontologie le plan déontologie dans
cette affaire
tout simplement si ça marchait bien
puisque comme il y avait eu des doutes
précédemment
politique c'est ça qui est profondément
choquant il vient d'avoir des élections
internes au rassemblement national
est-ce qu'ils sont allés voir comment
les choses se passaient non le le
l'objectif était de démontrer de porter
préjudice parce que dans l'article ils
disent que ça jette un soupçon sur la
sincérité qu'au fond euh
un tiers des deux tiers des rendez-vous
temps ne seraient pas de vrai votants
non c'est pas sérieux et très
franchement c'est choquant bon alors il
vous dites des suites juridiques
c'est-à-dire ben on examine les petits
plainte il y a une escroquerie il y a
une escroquerie qui a été réalisée
puisque
étendu que deux votants étaient des des
personnes physiques ce qu'elle n'était
pas et donc nous y réfléchissons
sérieusement vous réfléchissez à porter
plainte c'est ça bien sûr bon donc et
vous allez décider ensemble avec les
candidats avec votre avocat et les
candidats les candidats les candidats
également alors il y a quand même ce
deuxième tour entre cioti et Retailleau
quelle opposition quelle ligne selon
vous représentée par l'un et par l'autre
quoi alors moi j'ai toujours contesté
qu'il y avait une différence de ligne
entre les candidats et l'air parce que
au fond sur les les fondamentaux ils
sont d'accord vous ne trouverez pas
entre les candidats de différence
notable sur les questions de sécurité
sur les questions d'immigration sur la
reconnaissance du travail sur
l'importance portée au territoire
donc c'est moi une question de ligne
qu'une question de priorité de façon
pour lui dire
à droite je crois que
Eric Ciotti plus à droite et non
franchement sur les quais connu pour ses
connaissances en matière de de sécurité
de régalien d'autorité de l'État quand
j'écoute Bruno Retailleau objectivement
je vois pas de différence sensible entre
eux non je crois que
les choses se joueront davantage à la
personnalité à la à la capacité
de rassembler conviction à la façon
d'exprimer les convictions mais sur le
fond je vois pas de différence notable
entre eux peut-être sur les stratégies à
mettre en oeuvre au niveau de
l'organisation du parti mais bon ils
vont faire campagne ils vont chercher à
marquer leur point de convergence et
aussi leurs différences et puis et puis
le juge de paix sera l'adhérent et le
militant bon mais et la suite parce que
évidemment certains déjà chez DLR temps
de la main à Emmanuel Macron au
gouvernement Nicolas Sarkozy avait
réitéré son appel à Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que il n'y a pas un risque un peu
d'explosion derrière de du parti des
républicains j'entends cette question
depuis des années en réalité est-ce que
les républicains vont passer Fès c'est
ce que les républicains ne vont pas se
fondre dans la macronie est-ce que les
républicains ne vont pas exploser du
fait de leur différence de leur division
enfin cette mort annoncée lors de la
présidentielle moins de 5% oui bien sûr
bien sûr bien sûr non mais ça je ne le
dis pas mais on ne peut pas non plus
passer sous silence le fait que nous
sommes plus de 200 parlementaires que
nous avons fait au législatives le choix
clair de l'indépendance ni macroniste ni
le pénis que nous portons des
propositions singulières et que nous
avons un poids politique à l'assemblée
qui nous permet de faire avancer nos
propositions ce que nous demandons c'est
à être respecté dans notre indépendance
parce que je crois que la démocratie a
besoin de cette indépendance maintenant
pour les quelques personnes qui seraient
tentées de rejoindre la macronie on voit
quand même dans un passé récent que ça
n'a guère réussi ni à la macronie ni aux
intéresser eux-mêmes
moi je pense que le ralliement à la
majorité nous ferait définitivement
disparaître on a pour cela l'exemple
italien
la droite classique la droite de
gouvernement la droite républicaine
chaque fois qu'elle s'est alliée avec
les uns avec les autres et la disparu on
ne salit pas quand on est quand on est
fragile et la droite est fragile donc
elle doit son devoir c'est de se
reconstruire quoi qu'il en soit derrière
il s'agit de préparer la présidentielle
de 2027 c'est ça
Éric Ciotti ou Bruno Retailleau le
vainqueur devra préparer le terrain à
quelqu'un l'homme ou la femme
providentielle on parle en permanence de
de Laurent Wauquiez c'est aussi votre
sentiment alors je dirais que le rôle
d'un parti dans la mesure où celui qui
le dirigera ne sera pas candidat à la
présidentielle
est une évolution notable ça reconfigure
le rôle du parti le rôle d'un parti
c'est effectivement de veiller à ce que
l'outil militant soit vivant dynamique
prêt à s'investir pour les élections et
préparer les échéances qui nous
attendent mais ça ne se limite pas à
cela un parti politique doit aussi
travailler singulièrement le nôtre doit
travailler à son corpus idéologique si
on fait les choses de la même façon en
disant les mêmes choses on aboutira au
même résultat que celui que vous
évoquiez à la présidentielle on doit
vraiment réfléchir à
refonder notre partie c'est-à-dire
reconfigurer notre outil idéologique
reparler aux Français retisser le lien
de confiance avec les Français pouvoir
se faire réentendre des Français c'est
indispensable avant tout autre chose et
la bonne personne serait Laurent
Wauquiez en tout cas c'est ce que dit
erikiotti pour lui c'est assez clair
pour Bruno Retailleau ça l'est peut-être
un petit peu moins non je pense que ce
sera le rôle du président du parti dans
la perspective des élections de
l'élection présidentielle je pense qu'il
faut pas brûler les étapes bon il
appartiendra aux futurs président de ce
qu'il faut se tourner aussi à Nice vers
d'autres pour passer des alliances alors
d'un côté il y a Édouard Philippe qui
est quand même un ancien du camp des
républicains il y en a beaucoup qui sont
au gouvernement et puis de l'autre il y
a Éric Zemmour et puis le rassemblement
national est-ce qu'il faut essayer de
passer des alliances en vue de 2027
ensuite je crois que passer des
alliances
irréfléchies et possiblement
source de confusion ne serait pas bon du
tout pour les républicains moi je crois
qu'il faut nous remettre d'aplomb après
la défaite très sévère de l'élection
présidentielle on doit se remettre
debout on doit se renforcer on doit
retravailler nos idées retravailler
notre discours retravailler notre
organisation après seulement on
désignera notre champion et forcément il
faudra élargir notre électorat je parle
bien de notre électorat il faut que
qu'on reconquiert des électorats perdus
moi je ne vois pas quel type d'alliance
on pourrait conclure avec le
rassemblement national qui ne veut qui
ne veut qu'une chose qui est notre mort
de plus il y a des tas de choses qui
nous différencient du rassemblement
national prenons l'exemple de leur
proposition en matière économique et
sociales nous sommes antipodes des
propositions vous êtes plus proche
d'Emmanuel Macron non on va le voir sur
le sujet comme la réforme des retraites
que vous portez également dans votre
programme vous savez est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas un petit peu coincé bloqué
finalement vous savez
ce gouvernement qui finalement au bout
de plus de 5 ans aura augmenté les
prélèvements les dépenses publiques la
dette publique le déficit extérieur
l'insécurité l'immigration
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de droite dans ces
résultats je ne le vois pas le ministre
de l'Économie vient des républicains le
ministre de l'Intérieur vient des
républicains également
donc finalement oui mais pour appliquer
une politique qui n'était pas la nôtre
serait différente quoi différente alors
ça je peux vous l'affirmer un mot aussi
concernant les coupures de d'électricité
la menace est-ce que vous faites
confiance au gouvernement pour anticiper
les plans de secours alors bon bien sûr
je pense que le gouvernement fera tout
son possible pour un type pour éviter
les coupures qui sera vraiment
dramatique je voudrais dire que cette
agitation des menaces de coupure d'abord
créé beaucoup d'anxiété dans le pays et
même Emmanuel Macron dit l'impensable en
fait est possible quoi n'est pas
à étrangère ou fait que le Parlement
l'Assemblée nationale commence
aujourd'hui l'examen du texte du
Gouvernement sur les énergies
renouvelables c'est aussi une façon de
dire voyez pour combattre les risques de
coupure il faut des énergies
renouvelables quoi qu'il en soit
cette menace est le fruit d'une
politique énergétique aberrante conduite
depuis 10 ans par François Hollande puis
par Emmanuel Macron l'affaiblissement de
notre appareil nucléaire est un
véritable drame que nous payons cache
aujourd'hui songer qu'il y a il y a un
an encore nous exportions de
l'électricité aujourd'hui nous sommes
dépendants donc il y a une
instrumentalisation quelque part alors
le gouvernement pour faire passer des
textes comme celui sur les énergies
renouvelables le gouvernement veut
convaincre l'opinion publique que la
solution au manque d'énergie ce sont les
énergies renouvelées et moi je dis que
la solution à nos problèmes de
d'approvisionnement d'énergie c'est
d'abord dans la restauration de notre
appareil nucléaire qui a été gravement
mis à mal par les politiques publiques
conduites par François Hollande
[Musique]
dans un instant le grand matin Sud Radio
est de retour
[Musique]